salut à tous aujourd'hui toujours et
encore une nouvelle énigme c'est bientôt
la fin de ce petit jeu de l'été où je
vous ai donné une énigme par jour
pendant 32 jours et avant de vous donner
l'énigme d'aujourd'hui voici la réponse
à l'énigme d'hier la solution s'ils ne
l'avaient pas vu la vidéo d'hier
regardez là avant puisque là je donne la
réponse maintenant la réponse et 0,5
parce que tous les nombres sauf le zéro
bien sûr quand le divise par lui-même ça
donne un 20000 / 20 milles ça donne un
0,2 / 0,2 se donne un pizza par pli ça
donne 1 / une personne ça donne un donc
0,5 / 0,5
sa double ça donne un et 1 c'est bien le
double de 0,5 je trouvais ça marrant que
ça vous permettra peut-être de faire
votre petit malin de temps en temps avec
cette énigme ou avec l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui ça fait quelques jours que
je vous ai pas fait une énigme sous
forme de story donc pour l'énigme 27
petites story c'est un homme un
businessman qui demande à son veilleur
de nuit de le réveiller demain matin à 7
heures pour prendre son avion le
lendemain matin le veilleur de nuit
réveille son patron mais lui dit ne
prenez pas l'avion ne partez pas j'ai
fait un rêve cette nuit j'ai rêvé que
l'avion allait s'écraser il ya un grand
danger ne le prenez pas il est tellement
persuasif que businessman l'écoutent et
ne va pas aller report ne prend pas
l'avion et il s'avère que dans la
journée ils apprennent que l'avion s'est
effectivement écrasée qui a eu une
défaillance technique et que l'avion
s'est crashé le businessman appelle son
veilleur de nuit le remercie de lui
avoir sauvé la vie et en profitant même
temps pour lui licencier question
pourquoi le businessman a licencié son
veilleur de nuit
réfléchissez bien la question je pense
que vous pouvez la trouver vraiment
d'ailleurs dès que vous l'avez trouvée
ne mettez pas la réponse dans les
commentaires faut que les autres
puissent chercher mais mettez un pouce
en l'air qu'on voit le nombre de
personnes qui ont trouvé la bonne
réponse je vous laisse encore profiter
de ces derniers quelques jours du mois
d'août on va bientôt reprendre le
calendrier normal de la chaîne que vous
pouvez consulter dans le descriptif
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de
partir puisque le mental blog c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an
rendez vous demain 17h ciao